c'est devenu le symbole de la résistance
ukrainienne haïr pin le pont sous lequel
les civils en fuite sous les tirs des
russes cherchaient à s'abriter se tient
comme monument tordu à la bataille qui a
pu freiner l'avancée des soldats de
vladimir poutine vers le coeur de kiev
j'ai l'âme en paix dit le maire d'une
certaine façon mais autrement c'est
effrayant parce qu'on peut voir ce
qu'ils ont fait de la ville la
destruction que l'on voit c'est
principalement le résultat de notre
défense de la ville c'est la dernière
ville avant kiev qui a résisté et
maintenu ses défenses c'est d'ici que
l'ukraine a lancé une contre offensive
contre les troupes russes et nous avons
réussi
la ville héroïne a dit le président yves
hinse qui aujourd'hui ses habitants
commencent à y revenir
mais but come back nous avons peur que
les troupes russes puissent revenir
dit-il des informations circulent çà va
peut-être arriver dans deux semaines
avant le 9 mai jour de la victoire en
russie c'est une des dates favori du
président poutine alors nous avons tous
peur mais il faut rebâtir notre ville
maintenant
les soldats russes auxquels la ville
d'hier pin a tenu tête sont aujourd'hui
remplacés par une armée de bénévoles ils
brandissent de simples pelles et balais
si les combats ont pris fin avec spin
city si agosto mail que sont arrivés les
troupes russes en s'emparant de
l'aéroport m à rester chez elle la
plupart du temps dans la cave dans son
jardin dans les rues tout était trop
effrayant bureau systra ça faisait très
peur raconte t-elle ils fêtaient tout le
monde méchamment sans honneur vous ne
pouvez pas imaginez s'il y avait un
homme aux marchés le directeur il était
très gentil ils sont venus pour qu'ils
leur ouvre le marché et il a hésité un
peu et quand il a ouvert la porte il a
reçu une balle dans la tête et du pied
emma croyait que sa voisine s'était mise
à l'abri hors de la ville elle voulait
nourrir ses poulets quand elle a
découvert svetlana la dame s'était
réfugié juste en dessous dans ce réduit
son corps ne porte aucune trace de
violence c'est son père qui n'a
visiblement pas tenu le coup il y
retourne zai me retournais
personne ne sait quand c'est arrivé dit
emma elle était très accomplie elle
jardiner c'était une personne
merveilleuse et les parties
boris n'en pouvait plus de voir le corps
d'un jeune homme gisant au sol en proie
aux éléments et aux charognards il
portait une croix dit il c'était urgent
qu'il soit enterré il s'en est donc
chargé
on a mis une croix explique-t-il parce
qu'un orthodoxe doit être enterré sous
une croix il est enterré en surface mais
il doit être mis en terre correctement à
voir un prêtre qui chante un enterrement
humain voorhees pense que c'était un
jeune soldat ukrainien il a interpellé
l'armée à plusieurs reprises mais
personne n'est encore venu le réclamer
je n'ai pas vérifié s'il avait des
papiers d'identification peut être dit
il ils seront toujours là s'il le des
terres ils regarderont je ne sais pas
quand je les intéresse à tirer de tous
les côtés les roquettes volet n'était
pas en mesure de chercher ses papiers
pour moi c'était simplement une personne
borodianka a connu les combats sans
doute les plus féroces c'est une des
premières villes dortoirs autour de la
capitale qui a été visée par les frappes
aériennes au début de l'invasion le
passage des soldats russes ici à
transformer la ville en playboy entre
preuve disent les autorités que la
russie s'est acharné délibérément sur
les habitations civiles des édifices
coupée en deux par des frappes éventré
noircie par les flammes effondrés comme
des châteaux de cartes les autorités
pensent que près de 200 personnes sont
restées coincées dans les décombres
on les présume mortes dans les quartiers
résidentiels comme celui ci un bar à
janka qui ont été lourdement endommagées
par les banques demandé par les combats
les opérations de recherche ont été
retardés il fallait d'abord vérifier que
le terrain ne soit pas miner
les hommes les mêmes qui se sont lancés
sur les lieux de chacune des frappes
depuis plus d'un mois souvent sous les
tirs pour en extirper les blessés
travail aussi vite que possible mais
avec toute la prudence et la délicatesse
que permet la machinerie lourde qui les
assiste bien qu'on cherche surtout des
cadavres ici le chef des services
d'urgence se permettent encore d'espérer
un miracle
il ya trois jours dit il nous avons
frappé sur les dalles de béton et
quelque part à l'intérieur où nous avons
entendu quelqu'un frapper en retour nous
avons entendu un son c'est pour ça qu'on
commence ici dans cet édifice parce
qu'il ya encore de l'espoir que des gens
soient en vie ludmila et son mari igor
assistent à la scène l'estomac noué ils
n'ont pas bougé depuis le début des
travaux la soeur de ludmila et leur
neveu sont parmi les quatre personnes
que l'on croit ensevelies
ils ont frappé avec un missile depuis un
avion dit igor 1 a frappé ici et l'autre
la voyez igor lui s'interdit tout espoir
nous espérons seulement pouvoir les
enterrer aujourd'hui je suis désolé
si on peut plus les sauver eux et tout
ce que l'on cherche encore dans les
caves les sous les gravats on peut
peut-être leur offrir plus de dignité
dans leur peau que dans la mort ici
marie-eve bédard radio canada borodine
ce cas